John let me start with you is there a
different discussion about one
innovation is for cars away from the
auto industry than in the auto industry
I think so I mean if you look at the
exciting pictures that emerge this
weekend of this minivan decked out with
sensors that's alleged to be an apple
car you know you see technology for
doing very precise localization and
mapping some of the sort of parts of the
what's involved in the technical car and
so it is that it's a different sort of
set of techniques and skills then sort
of the traditional Detroit Auto making
industry tim higgins I love I don't
think what this one a story cross but
then I saw your violin oh yeah tim
higgins came from detroit where you
covered the automaker's you come here to
cover apple what are the similarities
between these companies Oh for one thing
apples a global company with a lot of
cash auto industry churns through cash
very quickly cause some rule of thumb is
it's usually about a billion dollars for
a new car to this created j'en they
caused a billion dollars to create a new
but kind of car generally speaking as
companies that are making cars for a
hundred years right I mean it's an
expensive time-consuming process so on
one hand Apple's got a lot of money in
the bank they got a lot of money 178
billion dollars so not short on cash
they've got global operations are used
to doing supply chain management around
the world they're used to doing
industrial design they're used to
dealing with the retail network all over
the world so in some ways they have a
lot of the things in place that a global
auto maker would have now that said you
know designing and building cars is very
complicated something that trips up even
long experienced automakers with
regulations and safety and marketing and
just hitting what the consumer wants
seven years down the road is a very long
lead time for developing a car so let's
talk about the R&D spending that those
companies already do they spend
boatloads of money in our d which is on
top of you know I don't know container
ships full of money i mean the history
that of knowledge that they've built up
well i guess that's the question is
there an accumulated bit of knowledge or
is it a calcified bureaucracy that
thinks about the way they do things as
opposed to what they would do with a
blank piece of paper they're gonna start
all over right when you talk to
engineers out in Silicon Valley they
find frustration when they deal
automakers they feel like they don't
move quick enough you talked to guys in
Detroit and they would say well there's
a reason why we're so slow some of it
has to do with safety and regulations
and dealing with just kind of the
challenges of putting a product on the
road where people's lives are going to
be in jeopardy or something goes wrong
but but more of that I mean is it about
the way that the cars I made those about
because they've got the wrestling with
union contracts and the wrestling with
existing factories and they're wrestling
with relationships with dealers that
they've got to figure out what to put
into their pipeline as opposed to put
what to put on the road they really have
a lot of legacy issues where is you look
at Tesla its emergence in the last few
years now you can say what you will
about their business model that they
have created a maybe an interest in the
auto space from new players who have
said look at the challenges in the past
but hey look at this new entrant they
are able to do what they can do in the
short amount of time what can other
folks do with a lot of money and I think
that's where some of the excitement is
coming from John when you look at the
excitement what is it technologically
that you feel like is right there ready
to be improved upon the most is it
battery is it is it the duration of the
battery is it self-driving aspects of
Road awareness I think it's safety I
think that the number of lives lost to
traffic accidents over 30,000 per year
in the US alone in a million worldwide
is just a tragedy and I think that with
the better sensors and artificial
intelligence algorithms coming online we
should have the capability to radically
reduce accidents so I think that that's
the thing that's really exciting about
what can happen now I mean safety is a
really great thing to talk about but
Apple Google these other companies in
Silicon Valley us are probably looking
at the idea of what the user is doing
with that time when they're driving
these are companies that really want to
create a business where your digital
life is at the center of their devices
right now when you're driving a car to
his point the idea of safety you're not
able to maybe fully engage in that
digital lifestyle so if you're pushing a
product that allows folks while they're
in the car to be in the digital space
either through autonomous driving or
through other kind of functions that
opens up a whole new marketplace for
commerce well there's a horrible irony
that the company is responsible for more
text driving accidents or at least some
way responsible giving people devices in
their hands for while they drive are now
looking at cars John Leonard I also
wonder if there is a different sort of
pace of innovation when you're sort of
safely aside from both but you've
witnessed what goes on a Detroit you've
seen all those engineering centers here
in Silicon Valley is there a different
pace of innovation in Silicon Valley I
think so i've been told that the typical
Silicon Valley investor wants to return
in 18 months or 24 months and that's
just very rapid turnaround I think
interestingly Google and building its
small prototype car is actually
partnering with companies in Michigan I
think that they've said that they want
to work with the sort of Detroit
ecosystem and so I think there's an
acknowledgement that it could be win-win
earth parts that Silicon Valley will be
good at the parts that's is sort of more
traditional Eastern us industries will
be good at and it could all come
together